for me or the people that I Mentor
growth is is a key habit I call 60
minutes of learning every day is is very
very powerful another great habit is the
five Great hours rule that I talk about
in the book it takes most producers two
weeks to do five worldclass hours of
work because we haven't set up our
ecosystem because we're constantly
checking our phone if you look the great
Geniuses they all had one thing in
common they spent long periods of time
alone in their work laab thinking about
solutions to their biggest problems set
up your devices so you can do real work
versus fake work and do five sweaty
intense Flow State hours versus playing
around and then after that You' get the
rest of the day off you know if you
start at 8 you finish at 1 you can go
mountain biking be with your family
enjoy your life do all those kinds of
things hey it's EV Carmichael and I
watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you people think they have to know how I
call the tyranny of how like you get all
excited I'm going to do this and then
your brain goes I've never done it
before Oh my God what did I say I don't
know how to do this and they tend to
focus on how to do it and when you start
with how you're screwed like Martin
Luther King had no idea how when he did
his eye of a Dream speech in fact his
wife was the one that pushed him because
he was uncertain right if you know the
real history it's pretty interesting but
the bottom line is he gets up there and
he gives his vision of how it can be
done he talked about what needs to
happen and why if you can figure out
what you want and why you want it and
you get strong enough reasons reasons
that'll drive you late at night it'll
get you up early in the morning and the
reasons are different some people do it
for nitty-gritty reasons Jim ran used to
say because you know some guy told him
he he borrowed money from this finance
company I forget the name of hfc Finance
whatever the hell it was and you know he
hadn't been back since he borrowed the
money you know so they're calling him in
those days they could harass you in ways
they can't today right they call him
show up embarrass him in front of his
neighbors and so Jim ran is first real
chunk of money he told me he made
because it's like he set this goal it
was his nitty-gritty reason his reason
to get rich was so he could go down and
paid this thing off and he said he went
to the bank and got it all in cash and
in small bills and he bolted into this
little hfc you know Finance place and
the guy who borrow the money was the
fourth best back and he said I walked up
there I open I opened up this brief and
I dumped all the money all over his desk
in small bills and I said count it it's
all there I will never be back he said
he was startled cuz I had been there
since I borrowed the money right but but
he did it for that great some people do
it for their kid some people will do it
like we almost all do it for something
more than ourselves some people do it
because they like winning right I know
that about you right it's like I like
winning I like being the best at what I
do so I'm not going to settle for less
than that why would I right so you got
to find your reasons but if you know
what you want and you get a big enough
wi now you'll figure out how to do it
but if you start with how you know the
small brain the fear brain go oh I
don't know what to do I don't know where
to go I don't know what to do 90% of the
time either I know what and why and then
I try some it doesn't work I try
something else I do something else now I
speed it up by learning from the best so
that's why you know money Master the
game is a perfect
example my companies you know at the
time were $100 million companies I had
one $500 million company now we're doing
7 billion I took what I learned from
these guys I applied it not only in my
investing I applied it to my own
business businesses why do I reinvent
the wheel when I just learned from the
best on Earth I mean somebody's that
good can tell you that little 2mm thing
that changes everything so my life is
really about learn from the best but I
don't start with the how I start with
the what and the why and I think that's
the mistake most people make rule number
three is challenge your limits with
David Goggins on the other end of
suffering is a life that many people
don't know even exist It's A Beautiful
World cuz we like like the 40 perent
rule we all live in this world where our
brains are keeping us in this
box outside that box on the other edge
of suffering which is all the of that
40% is a world that's endless of
opportunity but we are afraid to go
outside that box because in that box is
comfortable that's where all of our nice
stuff you know that's where the nice
four-lane highways at I know where the
restrooms are at I know where the gas
stations are at outside that box man God
gives you a shovel and says Man start
digging that's not fun but when you dig
you dig your own path to all kind of
stuff that's unknown and that's why I
started realizing man like on the other
end of this is some beautiful stuff so I
got outside my box and realized man 300
lb now look at me I'm 185 lbs and on the
other side of the box was all this stuff
and I didn't know was over there till I
climbed the wall and saw it so what wall
are you climbing now man right now I've
climbed a lot of walls there's no more
wall s anymore the reason why is cuz I
know how to
climb I was trying to figure out how to
climb before I got all the right gear
man I got the ropes I got the shoes I
got the chalk I got the harnesses I'm
good I'm not scared to climb anymore I
go to the Rock hammered in I got my bade
and I'm good to go so you got to figure
out how to climb first and that's all we
all have a different way of climbing
that's why there's a lot of books out
there on mental toughness it's all crap
why because it's a Cookie Cutter Way
life isn't cookie cutter like 3.14 is
pie it's how you figure out equations
we're all different equations we all
come from we all have a story we all
have to strengthen our mind to figure
out our own equation once you figure out
your own equation in life you can then
start picking way at how to be better
but you first have to figure out your
equation in life once you figure that
out man you can do anything also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number four is
focus on your energy with Mel Robbins
how do I use this energy exchange and my
intuition to spot the things that are
draining me dry and to let them go push
them off the branches get them out of my
life thank them for their purpose and
their service but then get out of here
because you need to make room for
something new and better and energizing
doesn't that sound good yeah you better
believe it sounds good so let's do it
and one of the reasons why I want you to
really focus on energy is because your
energy doesn't lie I mean just for a
second with me just take a
second whether you're out there walking
the dog or you're driving around in your
car or you're working from home or
you're busy doing a bunch of stuff I
want you to just stop for a
second and I want you to assess right
now what's your energy level think about
a fuel gauge in a car empty to full
empty in a human being means you feel
depleted you feel burnt out you feel
checked out you feel like your whole
life is basically pouring energy into
everything else full in a human
being basically means that you're
energized you're excited you feel like
the things that you're pouring yourself
into your habits your routine the people
you're surrounded with the projects
you're working on it may be difficult
but it's bringing energy back into your
life
too your energy never
lies we are energetic human beings and I
know that sounds woo woo we can get into
the Neuroscience on that on a totally
different episode but let me prove it to
you have you ever walked into say a
coffee shop and the person that is
behind the counter is having the world
worst day they are super grumpy it
doesn't matter how big your smile is it
doesn't matter how nice you are they are
like that
energy actually impacts you just like
your positive energy can impact somebody
else energy is contagious rule number
five is never think small with Arnold
schwarzen maker how would you suggest
people think of never think small or
what stories come to mind that from your
life
exemplify that well just just the very
beginning I mean for me to go and say I
want to compete in the junior Mr Europe
competition rather than just in the Mr
Austria competition it would I trained
just as hard as everyone else in the gym
the goal was just smaller they said I
want to be Mr Austria and I said I want
to be Mr Europe so I'm going to start
with Mr junior junior Mr Europe the best
build man of Europe I'm going to go to
this competition and I was thinking
bigger and I was training as hard as
they were everything was the same but
then when I won that competition because
I had a very clear Vision that's what I
want to win that immediately launched me
into getting
a job to become a trainer in Munich in a
bodybuilding gymnasium now imagine how
in heaven is that your young bodybuilder
you're 18 years old you just won your
first International competition you win
some local competition in Austria you
win some powerlifting competitions some
weightlifting competitions but now
you're junior Mr
Europe and you have this Trophy and now
you're getting a job to train in a
second biggest gym in Munich so that was
like absolute heaven so with 19 I
started training become the trainer in
the gym so now I had the
opportunity to train day and night when
they wake up because of I was sleeping
in the gym I was waking up and I was
training I was taking a nap in the
afternoon I was training I was going to
sleep before going to sleep at night
after dinner I was training I was
training day and night so this is a
dream but it was all because I thought
big they were still stuck working for
some bath house in Austria or for the
government or being a trash collector or
being a teacher or something like that
they were still stuck in the same job I
was already moving on to Munich and I
was already a trainer in a bodybuilding
gymnasium making this the launch pad to
America which was my Ultimate Dream so
this is what I'm saying so it didn't
take more work to thank big it's just
thinking big just thinking big makes you
bigger and what my point is is it takes
just as much effort so I my whole and I
learned again from bodybuilding from
that kind of thing I learned that don't
hold back so when I went within age of
19 I was the youngest Mr Universe
competitor I competed in the Mr Universe
contest and I I placed second I placed
runner up so that a year later I went
back with the age of 20 and one Mr
Universe the youngest Mr Universe ever
but this is all because I was thinking
big I wasn't saying oh maybe in a few
years from now I go there or I shouldn't
go there right now or something or it's
too early or this and then it's just
start thinking right way I'm going to go
for the second Mr Universe next year I'm
going to go to America I'm going to go
and make Joe weer aware of me and you
know make sure that I win another
competition and all so I was driven
bigger and bigger and bigger and even
when I got into acting I didn't look at
it as kind of like I'm going to get some
character roles I wasn't interested in
character roles I wanted to be another
Steve reefs or re Park they were the
stars of the Hercules movies cleaned
Eastwood was the star we always cleaned
Eastwood you know in a fist full of
dollars clean Eastwood in a dollar a few
dollars more clean Ewood in in in know
in this movie whatever it was it was
like I that's what I wanted Charles
Bronson I want to be like Charles
Bronson I want to be like Warren batty I
want to be like those guys that were the
top stars and that's what I saw myself
and they said well this ladder is very
hard to climb
up I said well then I build my own
ladder I built my own ladder and then I
know exactly how to get up there that's
exactly what I did I created my own way
of getting up there rule number six is
set boundaries with Simon cic I think
this whole idea of setting boundaries
you know it gets a little bit um
misunderstood right like everybody
thinks you to set boundaries which means
keep people away I refuse to do that
that's beyond my boundary I'm not doing
that no no no that's not what boundaries
mean what boundaries means are let me
tell you what I imagine and what my
limitations are we have boundaries in
relationships right you sit down with
with your partner you co-create the
relationship that you want to have and
if you're a good relationship you
discuss what the boundaries are that you
both agree to obey and it's not for us
to judge the boundaries of other
relationships based on the boundaries of
our relationships and vice versa right
we create the boundaries that make us
comfortable and we agree to stay within
those bound we can do whatever we want
inside those boundaries but we cannot
step outside those boundaries whatever
relationship Style want to have you got
to have boundaries and that is a
discussion and I think that is the right
thing to do in a professional
circumstance as well it was always
assumed that there's only one kind of
boundary right which is the one I have
right right right and if you go to work
till 10 o'clock at night and work on a
Saturday you do it make it happen right
yeah but that's not the reality of a
Young Generation anymore but we're not
having the discussion what we what we've
confused is boundaries as a conversation
versus boundaries as a um unilateral
wall that says I'm not doing that and
you kind ask me to do that right it
should be a conversation which is
somebody says look I'm not interested in
moving up the ranks I want to be treated
fairly I want to be paid fairly I'm
going to do good work but I don't want
to work late at night and I don't want
to work on weekends because I want to
live lifestyle and I'll say okay like an
only relationship let's have a
negotiation right which is I'm cool with
that every now and then
every now and then when whe there's a
lot of stress and things have gone
Haywire or we have a huge deadline I may
need you to stay late a couple nights or
the occasional Saturday but I'll give
you Monday off I'll make it up to you
I'm not going to take away from you
without giving you back and I won't do
it a lot I won't abuse it but every now
and then are you okay with that boundary
the flexible boundary yes right so I
hear what the boundaries are you want
you understand the things that I need
and we come to an agreement say yes
those are the boundaries we we're both
we're we're all clue with that we're in
alignment we're in alignment and that
becomes more productive but that's not
what's happening usually the discussion
of boundaries is me telling you and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is believe in
yourself with Gary V my conviction and
confidence and bravado is very high I
believe in myself I don't even think I'm
comfortable expressing how much I
believe in myself that's luck of DNA
that's my mother there's a lot of things
that went into it but it's the truth I
truly believe that I am special and
Ultra capable in a world of 8 billion
people on the flip side the reason it
works is cuz I think humility is the
other thing that makes me work as much
as I think I'm special I think there's
been many special people I think there's
many special people right now I think
there's been millions of special people
through the years of life and I know
that if God forbid I pass away tomorrow
that I will get a good 24 hours on
social media everybody will share their
favorite video and if they met me and
this and oh sh just in Brazil and and
then everybody will move on so I believe
I believe in being competitive but being
a sportsman I believe in a lot of things
that seemingly look opposite the biggest
one I believe in is in ambition and
patience almost everybody who consumes
my content when they hear patience hears
complaints not
patience right so I go so hard every day
I mean look at me what I'm doing now
midnight flight from New York fly here
I'm literally going to the airport right
now back to New York bagging up my body
going hard but I believe in patience
slow it will all
come Excellence is the pursuit of
perfection so we're never done what's
the perfect interview what's the perfect
question what's the perfect thumbnail
who's the perfect guest what's the like
you're never done it's it's never done
uh but that Pursuit is how we become
excellent what's a perfect workout
what's a perfect book again it's never
done but in the pursuit you become more
and more and more excellent and I think
you'll see that across High Achievers
nobody ever says they're done nobody
ever says this is it it's perfect like
there's always new things that you want
to add and tweak and change and people
to confer with and help um and always
new problems to go off and solve and so
it's it's getting dedicated to the
process um and that you're getting
better every day which is which is hard
because that means you're going to fail
and you're going to suck and you're
going to make mistakes and you won't
know uh until you get out there no
matter how much market research you do
you don't know till you start going off
and do it no matter what recipe you
follow a workout regimen you look at uh
you never know until you start going and
do it and people get overwhelmed by the
options this is the problem you know if
back to the world you came from with all
of the fitness and diet and everything
else it's like okay I'm going to you
start with a goal of I want to get into
a healthy weight right I I want to get
down to my high school weight or
university weight or whatever and that's
a very clear tangible great goal like
let's get healthy but then how do you do
it do you go on the keto diet or the
carnivore diet or the vegetarian diet or
the vegan diet or the Mediterranean diet
and and are you fasting intermittent
fasting water fasting coffee fasting you
know are you doing working out are you
crossfitting are you yoga are you doing
high in low int this like it's just it's
just this NeverEnding cycle of more and
more and more things to learn where you
will never learn everything it's
impossible to know everything and so you
need to just start and you learn more in
the process of doing then you will just
researching researching researching and
like planning to get a plan uh and so
that's what you find with the at least
that's what I found with the world top
Achievers is they have this North Star
that they're shooting towards and that
is a bold Noble EXC excellent even
perfect goal and then how you get there
is super messy and very chaotic and full
of mistakes but they're willing to go
and make mistakes because the goal
itself is Noble the reason so many
people aren't productive throughout the
day is not only because they don't have
their purpose and their psychology and
their physiology supporting them but
also because they're going through the
day in an ignorant way you know they're
going through the day Focus solely on
responding to everybody else's emergency
you know here's what most people do they
wake up they get ready for the day they
go through the they go to work they're
not really thinking about anything yet
they're just kind of going through the
motions they get to work and what do
they do they open up their email inbox
which is the worst thing you could ever
do to be productive your inbox is a nice
organizing system of other people's
agendas that's what an inbox really is
it's a nice organizing system other
every email in there is someone needing
something for from you or pulling from
you that's what most of them are isn't
it true and so what most people do is
they open up their inbox and they start
responding to other people's emergencies
or they start they start looking through
all their emails to see well what am I
supposed to do today or what's the
biggest fire I have to fight today in
other words they're living their life in
reaction versus living their life in
intention in intelligence in Direction
they're not focused on what to do
throughout the day they're just saying
well do this because that's what popped
up today you know so for personally I
never even check email until 10:00 a.m.
when I get up and I'm looking at
everything I'm sit down and I strategize
my day before I ever even think about
checking my email and then I might only
check my email once or twice a day
because I set up all other systems to
support my ability to be productive
because in your life I'm guessing that
you're only really making money if
you're producing and in my my industry I
live in the experts industry that's the
sort of the self-help spirituality
business growth world where we offer
advice to other people about how they
can improve their life or build their
business that's the expert industry in
the expert industry most people are
really struggling to be productive
because we're creatives right we have so
many great ideas and so many great
intentions throughout the day and we
have so many ideas we can never actually
accomplish them maybe you're the same
maybe at base you're really a Creator
and you have all these ideas of so many
things you want to do but you've never
really been able to organize them and
get them done because haven't set up
systems to support your levels of
productivity let's start with at the
beginning of your day uh I'm going to
just jump into one little thing that I
do at the beginning of the day it's not
at the very beginning but I think it
will help you and it's a way of
organizing my
day and I call this onepage productivity
it's just a simple sheet of paper that I
have that I fill in when the morning
after I've gone out and I've exercised
that's a piece of my morning activity is
mastering my physiology so I can become
a high performer starts with me drinking
lots of water in the morning eating the
right things going for a little quick
run or workout or even just a brisk walk
to energize my body and my mind so that
I can be creative and think and when I
get back to my office and it's time to
actually work I do this onepage
productivity sheet and this one-page
productivity sheet helps me really think
through what I need to do throughout the
day so here's the three elements of this
and by the way below this video you can
download the sheet and you can use it on
your daily life let me walk you through
how to use it basically there's three
elements of the onepage productivity the
first element is Major
projects these major projects usually if
you any given person probably has oh I
don't know you know like three big
buckets of projects that they're working
on so I might be working on you know
writing a new book I might be working on
doing a new seminar I might be working
on you know reinvigorating my online
marketing those are big big these are
big bucket projects that aren't
necessarily they're not the priorities
for the day these are the big Vision
these connect me to the what are the big
things I'm doing and any given person if
they're well organized they're probably
only working on three maybe five main
projects so what I want you to do when
you start out in the morning to keep you
big thinking big and thinking outside of
just the day to focus is you know and in
in the high performance Academy we've
already talked about purpose so we're
already engaged there okay this is just
a little snippet I want you to think
about the big picture of your projects
and I want you to think about what are
the five
things that you would have to do to move
these projects forward this is not five
things that you need to move them
forward today that's your priorities
your projects are just in general what
are the big things that you need to do
the big five things that you would have
to do so for example if online marketing
is one of my big projects in rein one of
the things I might have to do is learn
to code a web page right or learn to
design a web page now that's a project
it doesn't mean that today I'm going to
learn how to do it it just means in
general that's one of the things I will
have to do so these are what are the
five big things you would have to do to
actually make that project come into
fruition what would you have to learn
what would you have to go out and master
what would you have to who would you
have to contact what are the things you
would have to do for your big projects
next is people category in this people
category I want you to think of two
things in the people category the people
category is really important for high
performers cuz High performers really
get ahead not just because of who they
know but how they're engaging who they
know right what they're asking for what
they're doing so the people category
that I want you to think of each morning
on this onepage productivity is two
categories one I want you to sit down
and think of who do you need to reach
out to today who do you need to reach
out to so if I want to learn coding as
an example in general I might want to
schedule some time with a code or a web
designer so I'm like I'm going to have
to reach out to a coder or web designer
today and this is important because most
people when they open up their inbox
they just start replying to all these
things when I open my inbox the first
thing I do is I send out these emails
people I need to reach out to it's the
first thing that I do when I open my
inbox as an example very first thing is
send out all the emails of people I need
to reach out to the second category
here is the people that you are waiting
on right
given any person's real schedule you're
waiting on somebody to give you some
information or a decision to move
forward in your day isn't it true you're
waiting on something from somebody so
that you can move forward and most
people they just sit there and they wait
for the email to pop up they they hope
that it's going to come they don't do
anything about it the second thing I do
when I open my inbox after I reach out
to the people I reach out to the people
who I'm waiting on and I say something
specific to them so let me give you an
example of how this actually might
operationalize in the day when I open my
inbox I'll look in my emails for these
people first and foremost it's the first
thing I'll do after I send out the ones
I need to reach out to strategically
I'll say who am I waiting on I'll look
at and I'll open up their inbox or open
up their email to see if I got what I
needed if I didn't I send an email right
back to them to make sure I get what I
need as fast as possible so yes there's
an element of you hounding people to
become productive you know most people
are just sitting around waiting for
other people to help their dreams come
true for me I'm chasing people down
right you know I want to for high
performers there's a level of impatience
there you know if you want to become a
high performer you got to have this
level of impatience that says I need to
accomplish this I need to do this let's
go let's go let's go you need to be on a
faster path in life not stressed out
more but more focused on achieving what
you need to do to become happy to become
successful not just because someday
that's going to happen for you but in
the moment in the moment being happy and
successful so that you can be happy and
successful hope that makes sense
ultimately that's the people category
then the next
category is the priority category okay
your priority category is what are the
10 things that you've got to accomplish
today these are the 10 must do items
this is sort of like your to-do list but
it's ranked in the order of most
importance so very simple right because
to-do list are great I'm all for them
I'm all for day planners because it
helps you achieve some of these things
but at the end of the day you got to
think about okay what are my real
priorities today and here's what I'll
often do depending on how big these are
and how important they are when I get to
my when I've written all these out
here's how my day works here's the order
of things that I'll achieve throughout
the day first I'll do whatever it takes
to achieve these priorities whether it
is sending an email or whether it is you
know running an errand or whether it's
calling somebody these priorities in my
day happen first often before I even
open my inbox or if I have to open my
inbox I'll wait but priorities first
accomplish these first no matter what
these get done first before I respond to
anybody else's emergency or go through
all my inbox these
first then I move up second I'll go okay
who am I waiting on and who do I need to
reach out to the people category I'll do
that now often this will take most of
the entire day and then I'll say if
there's any given time left in the day
I'll Focus back on the bigger projects
thinking about what it's going to take
to accomplish them let's just say that
lack is ingrained in there you got the
story you lived on the streets you lost
everything you got betrayed your
business partner took everything took
your wife took you got the story in the
half okay okay you got to start telling
a new story of the future right you got
to believe in that future more than you
have to believe in the past so how do
you do that M you only believe in the
past when you feel the emotions of the
past the only time you're going to
believe in the future is when you feel
the emotions in the future right okay so
in order for us to change a belief or
perception about our s and our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwire
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body
and your body literally has to respond
to your mind that the choice that you're
making to change in that moment becomes
a moment in time that you never forget
now here's the key physically physically
the stronger the emotion you feel when
you make that choice the more you
remember the decision okay so then how
do we downregulate that old belief if
the trauma created emotional quotient of
six or seven then your decision to
change your belief's got to be n right
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
cuz you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotions right but the amplitude
of that emotion is greater than the
Betrayal Boom the body starts responding
to the mind and you're actually giving
your body a taste of the future
emotionally so you brand your impossible
no your body is actually getting the
taste of that future event it's
experiencing the future now ex big
explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life be begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack we in lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then
the side effect of the beginning of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you you'd rather hold on to your
lack the pain suffering rather tell the
story of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
it's about who you become mhm so the O
overcoming process becomes the becoming
process and so many people come through
this work they want abundance they want
healing they want a new relationship
they want a new career they want the
mystical but really they want wholeness
and and they want healing they want
peace they want wholeness cuz they feel
onho well well when you're in lack or
you're in separation you're not whole
imagine feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really enjoy a meal then you can
really enjoy your friends then you can I
I I I talk to people that are very
abundant I mean in the billions abundant
and you know so many of them say we are
in misery whole we're in agony because
they can't enjoy life anymore that's
what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want wherever they want that's
Freedom right people want abundance the
sponsoring thought is really they want
freedom right or whatever their
sponsoring thought would be right one of
the things that will help you to do the
work to create the things that you want
in your life is is it will help you if
you train your mind to start spotting
evidence as you're doing the work as
you're going through your day it will
help you if you train your mind to start
scanning the world and spotting evidence
that yes indeed the world is sending you
positive signals that things are going
to work out now why is it important to
train your mind to help you get what you
want well the reason why is because if
you get into a negative mindset if you
start
thinking this business is never going to
work why even bother or I'm never going
to meet anybody it's nothing but losers
out there look at all these idiots on
hinge why the hell should I keep doing
this if you allow your mind to start to
rest in a pessimistic negative
protective scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reason why there's nobody on hinge worth
talking to your mind will continue to
show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend Karen Crabtree always talks about
that transformational moment and when
your mind goes negative your mind starts
to scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that only
happens like once in my lifetime those
numbers are going to line up like that
today is a really cool day let's go do
something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself where you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this
guys what shape is that that right there
is a
heart there we go check that out if you
say brain mind show me a heart today
guess what's going to happen that damn
dog biscuit it's going to show it's
going to you're going to be like there's
a heart you're going to look out at the
sky and you're going to see a heart
shape oh right there in the mountains
there's a heart shape in the mountains
in southern Vermont you're going to see
it in the clouds what you're doing when
you tell your mind what's important to
you is you're telling your mind and the
the filter in your brain to change in
real time and allow into your
Consciousness what's important to you
and if you want to see hearts by God
those damn dog treats are going to start
looking like hearts everybody that's how
you train your mind it's freaking
incredible and if you want to see
evidence of this follow me on social
media if you follow me Mel Robbins on
social media you will see every day I am
reposting your stories of finding heart
shapes around the world now why is this
important well it's important because
it's a simple way to prove to you that
your mind changes in real time that if
you get serious about becoming more
positive and optimistic and encouraging
of yourself if you get serious about
saying this I don't want to see all the
reasons why I'm unhappy I don't want to
see uh everybody else in the world
that's launched a business or that's
lost weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or Rel
relationship and I don't want to see
that and and and have my mind process it
as evidence that it's never going to
happen for me I want my mind to
reprogram itself and see other people's
businesses and see other people getting
healthy and see other people in
relationships and I want my mind to say
yeah if they can do it I can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can I if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that when
you see what other people have and you
don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have have the power
to train your mind to filter the world
differently just like you woke up and
you saw the date today 22222 and your
brain saw that and was like whoa this is
a once- in a-lifetime day
everybody you are never going to have
another day that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow something cool could happen and if
you tell yourself something amazing is
going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horse everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system the reticular activating system I
call it the RAS I like to think about it
like a giant hairnet on your head and
this Ras sits over your brain I'm
probably getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just just means
that things are able to twist and bend
and change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat heart SP look at that there's a
heart right there see this
line that's called The Terror barrier
yeah jumping at you isn't it and on the
other side of the terror barrier is
something we call free
freedom and you know very few people get
through that Terror barrier it's rather
sad freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone that canot live the
way they want to
live
see why don't they why don't
they they don't know and they don't even
know they don't know now I'm going to
show you why people experience buyers
remorse when they buy something they
really want then they back away or they
go to move and they don't they go to
change jobs and they don't they go to
move to another city and they don't why
fear causes them to stay where they
are there's the individual the X
represents the unknown factor the
Paradigm now there's a power flowing
into this individual's mind and they can
make anything out of it they want
remember we said we had the ability to
choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration the
vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call
feeling when a person says they feel
this way or they feel that way what
they're really doing is describing the
vibration they're in now they choose
thoughts that harmonize with the
vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're
comfortable now let's move ahead let's
take a look here those people are
getting X Type results and they don't
like it you know what the problem with
them they're in bondage these people are
locked
up you
know Paradigm is like keeping a person
in a prison only there's no locks on the
door they can open the prison to walk
out into Freedom anytime they want and
they don't they keep getting the same
results over and over and over again
they're in bondage now let's go ahead
here's the same person X Type
conditioning X typ vibration the power
is flowing into them and for some
strange reason from Left Field b boom
incomes A Y type idea what is the Y type
idea the Y type idea represents anything
that you might want want to do that
you're not doing it might be moved to
another city change jobs sell the house
buy the farm whatever it may
be ask the little girl for the date ask
the guy to go to
lunch go make the
sale buy what you want go where you want
to go that's the why idea but as long as
the why idea is just in the conscious
mind it's just going to be an
intellectual ual exercise it's never
going to
happen so how do we make it happen well
that's when everything goes haywire here
we are here same person okay the power
flows in and what do they do they got
the Y type idea now for some strange
reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved that they're going
to act on that idea they don't
understand what's going to happen but
clearly understand this your central
nervous system is the most complex
electrical system in the
universe the central nervous
system is mindboggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subjective mind that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an ex XY vibration it's not
in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable able no on
a conscious level everything's going
crazy on a conscious level we experience
doubt the doubt turns into an emotion
called fear and that fear is expressed
through the body as
anxiety see that person is getting
emotionally involved to move ahead do
you know what happens they hit that
Terror barrier and they bounce off it
and right back into
bondage and they're so relieved to get
back
there they're back where they're
comfortable
they've canceled the sale they've
decided not to move they're going to
stay in the job that they don't like at
least they're
comfortable now that's not a very good
way to live and you know something
that's something everybody experiences
if they're going to grow you're going to
hit that Terror barrier see the terror
barrier is going Beyond where you're at
going to a new level I'm going to tell
you something when I set a goal if if if
it doesn't scare and excite me at the
same time I know I'm going in the wrong
direction now I also understand that my
Paradigm is going to try and get me to
bounce back to where I was it doesn't
want me to move
ahead I don't want to live there I lived
there for the first 26 years of my life
and for the last 50 I've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up they got
emotionally involved in the Y idea that
moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability they'll never be
able to pay for it they they experience
fear the fear expresses itself as
anxiety and bang you bounce off that
Terror barrier and you're right back oh
I might not be earning much here but I
know what it is I I I would love to move
there but I'm comfortable here I think
I'll just stay here these people are
acting like they have a contract to live
forever and they don't do you know what
to do say I'm going to get rid of all
that I understand it's there but I don't
want any part of it and I'm going to go
crashing right through that Terror
barrier now does that get rid of the X
energy no the X
energy is still there you see but at
least you're over into Freedom you made
the move you did it and if you continue
to feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go
away and you know where you're living in
Freedom you're living where you want to
live buyer's
remorse is when you cancel the
sale buyer's remorse is when you stop
just before you buy what you really want
before for you go for the thing that's
going to change your life and you know
it it's not moving to the other city
it's not starting the business of your
dreams it's not stepping out and betting
on
yourself that's a terror barrier that's
causing that and if you don't learn to
go through the terror barrier I'm going
to tell you something you're going to
stay right where you are for the rest of
your days that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell
say so
true they cave you fear to enter holds
the treasure you seek I know you all
have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do you've got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create to
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you you'll fall off and and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like what what happened I said I was
going to be nicer it's that you didn't
set up the most important thing you
needed to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what what do I mean by that well let's
say you want to become a a better person
you know you want to become more kind
more patient more loving with people now
you can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision your journal or
set up on a vision board that you look
at once in a while but in daytoday life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this is going
to be so basic you're going to laugh and
then I'll also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you could meditate in
the morning saying today I'm going to be
more present and calm and you you could
you can start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've Ted to do this
hundreds of thousands and they tell me
all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths reground myself
here we go you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
Behavior I know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
cuz they never set those things up so
what if you did it with an alarm so for
example for me on the opposite Spectrum
I don't want to just be calmer and more
present I Want More Energy throughout
the day so here's what I do one of my
big trigger moments is every time my
butt hits a chair I don't care if I'm on
a plane or I was like where we're
shooting here I I wrote a lot of my
books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercise just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just 2 to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that 2 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah you
know why because I'm triggered my day so
that my energy is maintained throughout
the day makes sense right this could be
as simple as let's say you want to be
healthier in your life okay let's set up
some trigger moments for you in this way
let's say every time you drop off the
kids on the way back to the house you
stop at the grocery store and get some
fresh produce that's just a trigger it's
like okay did one thing drop kids off
now tied to that triggered from that
action drop kids off is go to health
food store or let's say you want to get
healthier in the morning one of the
easiest ways to help people maintain a
better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your your mind that you've associated
with that door frame so let me give you
an example if I walk into my house at
night if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times and now when I walk through a
door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember
remember to be those three words so what
words would you love to have describe
you as a person that you would be happy
if that was how people described you
what would those words be have those and
now set them up in your life I teach
Executives to do this as well I have
them have a doorframe trigger when they
walk into their office in the morning
soon as they walk through that doorf
frame they have boom three words go
through their mind about how they want
to be perceived as a leader I have them
set up another door every every time
they walk into a meeting into the
conference room when they walk through
the doors of the conference room they
have another three words that trigger
off for them and it just reminds them
how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people think they have
to completely change their life what
would change your life completely is
setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes to
me a breakthrough is a moment in time
it's a moment when the impossible
becomes possible and you don't just
think about it but you act upon it you
know it's like you can have a concept
that doesn't create a breakthrough the
Breakthrough is when you get to the
point where you actually going to do
something about it and I ask people all
the time I ask your listeners or viewers
as well it's like I'm sure you've had a
time where you struggle with something
right you're going to do something about
this relationship but you keep not
changing it right you know pulling back
or you're going to stop smoking or
you're going to go lose those 25 lbs or
whatever it is and you start to make
progress and then you pull back and you
get disappointed and get frustrated but
then there's sometimes where finally you
hit this threshold you hit this moment
where your brain says not in another day
not in an hour I'm changing this
relationship I'm losing this weight I'm
making this happen and people create
that breakthrough and it can be happen
you know it's the difference between
what triggers it versus what makes it
possible what triggers it is usually
pain or massive inspiration nothing in
between does it most people they hit a
threshold of pain and say it's like like
you know I asked people how many of you
ever been in a relationship way too long
and everybody raises their hand I go why
why'd you stay you weren't happy they
weren't happy it's just because of the
unknown the uncertainties the the idea
of change it could be worse you know to
be alone but then there's that moment
when you finally hit the threshold you
go it's been painful in the past it's
painful now it's going be painful you
I'm going to change it now so the
trigger that finally made that happen
I'd ask your audience if they think of
something where they finally broke
through what was the trigger usually
that moment that day you hit a threshold
of I can't take anymore I'm changing or
something inspired you you saw some was
possible they can do it I can do it as
well but that's what makes it possible
what makes it last is a change in your
emotions or a change in your belief
system or a new strategy right you and I
both know because you're both
strategists the right strategy hell you
can consume a book and remember more of
it in 30 or 45 minutes than you did when
you used to spend 10 days on the damn
book right you know it's the right
strategy but you're not going to find
the strategy until it's a must for you
and not a should you know I mean or it's
that change in belief it's like okay
I've put up with this crap long enough
I'm better than this there's something
more in me that you finally find in
yourself or you finally get pissed off
enough or you get excited enough to make
that real change and so what I've
studied is I like to take complex things
and make them simple because I found
that you know the more you know when I
was really young I Tred to make things
more complex I think to try to convince
myself how smart I was or other people I
don't know what but it's stupid cuz
complexity is the enemy of execution and
the only way your life changes or your
business changes is execution so it's
like how do you make it simple and I
started looking at all these you know
I've been doing this this my 45th year
doing this I started when I was two of
course and and I started seeing these
patterns all over the world working with
the greatest people on Earth athletes
business people the most challenged
people in prisons like what are the
common denominators in all these
cultures and they began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
want to change their Finance they look
for a strategy which makes common sense
that's what I used to do but the problem
is strategy could be the problem and
maybe you need a better strategy but
that's not usually the real problem
right like for example 34 of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world uh we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the 1% know
it or cost of Fortune to do it no you
have to be fighting not to see all the
strategies to make your body physically
better they're around you everywhere so
it's you could have the wrong strategy
like I remember years ago on a cover of
Time Magazine they had the Atkins diet
and they said you know I think it was
15% of Americans were doing it well if
you got to pee on a stick so you don't
get too acidic and your breath is that
bad it's pretty obvious that's not
sustainable so sometimes it's a strategy
problem but when you work for the how
first and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way it's the
wrong SE sequence it's like the dog bit
Johnny Johnny bit the dog same words
different experience of your Johnny so
strategy naturally is where people go
but rarely do they change with that what
the real problem usually is the story
they've developed and a story is just
code for all the things you told
yourself over and over again till you
believe them right there's an old
language pattern that says tell I big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
who said that and so most of us are Lear
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what what do people say
how come I can't lose weight I can't
lose weight because you know I've tried
everything no if you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried
hundreds to name them and then they'll
tell you three stupid things that don't
work that they did over and over again
right so it's the story I I I don't have
a relationship cuz all the good ones are
gone or they're gay and I'm not or I'm
gay and they're not or whatever the
story is the story is what'll keep you
like I'm sure you know Jim you've have
so many great strategies you share with
people Haven you had times when you give
someone an answer right there in front
of them and they just can't even see it
right they don't believe it cuz the
story is literally blinding them in
Psychology we call a scuta a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
even the story and that's your state the
mental emotional physical state you're
in because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state you can have
all the brain capacity in the world but
you're not going to use it and so when
you're in a lousy State you come up with
a lousy story and then no strategy works
it doesn't matter what it is if and I
don't know if you've ever noticed if you
ever gotten really angry at somebody and
then suddenly you remember all the ways
they've ever screwed you over you've
been upset with them right but on the
other hand you fall in love and what's
wrong with life nothing I have no money
it doesn't matter we're in love it's all
wonderful right so the sequence in which
we do things accelerates or decelerates
or stops progress when it comes to a
breakthrough and what I found is change
the state first if you like we can you
and I can talk and give people a million
strategies but if I'm sitting here at
home in this state and I'm just
listening like this and nodding like
this yeah that makes nothing's going to
happen so the reason that I've done
events over my lifetime and the reason
why I do immersion events you 10 12 14
hours a day you learn a little bit at a
time like language you don't remember
the language a few years later but I
drop you in Rome and say you got no
teacher and you got 60 days I'll be
picking you up I'll pick you up 60 days
and now you're going to be speaking
Italian right especially if I put you
maybe with some passionate people who
are really going for it in their life
you're going to have a whole different
state about you you're going to develop
a new story and you're going to figure
out the strategy so I think the the
challenge for most people especially
with covid is we've all had our state
dropped people have been isolated
they've been pushed at home
they've had expectations that have
fallen away like I remember a year ago a
lot of people are like all right we got
vaccines now it's a new year it's going
to be a brand new thing you know
2021 now this year you talk about people
don't even have any goals or anything
because they've gone into learned
helplessness because they've been
disappointed so many times they start
thinking the problem is forever no
problem is forever no war is forever no
pandemic is forever your your mind is
weak now and it's gotten a weak habits
and you're in a lowered state so you
start to believe that and so it's like
you got to change people's State first
then you got to give them the story that
can help them then you give them the
strategies that work and there even if
you don't give them the strategy they'll
figure out their own strategy you're a
perfect example of that right you
figured it out because you got yourself
to the point where it's like I've got to
turn this around and then you have
something that you can give and that
expands your life as you've experienced
J for the seven steps to Har your inner
confidence check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there confidence is the willingness to
try confidence is an action that's what
it is and this phenomenon has been
heavily researched by social
psychologists and there's even a term